all right I probably always gonna be on
your corner okay how do you choose who's
in your corner it's just my preference
whoever I want do you know what it up
each file like Duke right it all depends
yeah I mean usually it's Duke but um
what's crazy is Rufus Duke reverse V I
know I know the game Rufus for best team
in the world to raise ah yeah alpha male
guy brothers you have Tyron yeah you
have Ben Askren yeah yeah still in Asia
he does he he does I mean he comes back
here but he's got a deal he'd be trans
out of all when he's gone away from them
for like a couple weeks they tell you
something about your boy tyron woodley
the Carroll oh jeez he carefully I'm
going to be very sure I'm gonna tread
very lightly is a big big strong man
dude is the most unentertaining finer
but you're judging that off on fight no
did you even Thompson fights did you
last fight I just saw him fight um last
time Demian Maia Demian Maia you ever
watched Demian Maia versus Anderson
Silva oh that was the worst in up in
Saudi Arabia yeah yeah he's boring the
climates weird the elevation I've been
there yeah oh you have it I had been
there okay
the elevate I couldn't even talk about
walk I was the elevation was so high I
don't know much about the elevation I
don't know anything about back I love
tiring I love him I love to look at me
Tyrone Tyrone Tyrone who gave you
cocaine no one week okay
I just you're hyper as [ __ ] right now
pay some respect we love you Tyron
Woodley my god I love Rufus support you
don't think I do that right now
Harris legend Ruta Lee legend you're a
legend I'm [ __ ] a big fan surgery and
they're my favorite and Sergio's he's
close to Giorgio who is brother he has a
brother both his favorite team Rufus
Porsche
I've never heard of surgery I heard of
Anthony I would love to have tyron
woodley on this show and you tell him
exactly what you told you know why I
don't want a minute in this in this
world why because I don't want to fall
asleep because this fights are so
[ __ ] boring it's okay this is no shut
up I don't give a [ __ ] this is a co-main
event we paid money to see this are you
can you not like can you just get in the
pocket and [ __ ] do some punches the
juice Stephen Thompson fights first one
was great so what that's equally on
Stephen Thompson's party you think I
unfollowed Stephen Thompson on every
piece of social media because of that
for Stephen Thompson Stephen Thompson
was very boring in that fight at least
Tyrone knocked him down
beautiful you're right both right sorry
you're right he's your brother and
comrade here comrade your brother and
I'm being confrontational very and I
don't want to die and I just realized
he's huge what I just did these are
[ __ ] beasts these are human machines
and I'm in the [ __ ] right barn are you
my Schneider one I will take on the
whole army yeah bring me all of them no
should we all right now kid train in
Milwaukee bring him can I just say there
[Music]